why hello there
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message for today may
3rd 20 21 and whether you're locked down
or living in a free state i welcome you
equally to this show to hopefully learn
a little something
perhaps smile once or twice and maybe
just maybe
lessen your desire to kill random people
uh if you haven't please subscribe
by clicking that little bell up there
and then if you actually click within
the bell you can click another thing to
actually see our videos it's a whole
it's a whole to do people do all that
and then maybe our videos will show up
in your
youtube news feed and we've got three
stories for you today first off
jimmy kimmel who's a late night comedian
i suppose
on abc really pretty awful guy who's of
course
done blackface at least once and i think
probably a couple of times well he went
off on
south carolina senator tim scott who
gave the rebuttal to joe biden's speech
last week that we covered of course
and kimmel just had some really really
awful things to say
that are a true indicator of modern
what i would say is the modern
pernicious racism of the left it's not
this overt racism like oh you can't use
that water fountain which by the way
there's pretty much nobody in america
that thinks that something like that
should be
it's this new sort of underhanded racism
so we're going to play a clip
get to that and then caitlyn jenner who
right now is running for governor of
california
and by the way caitlyn's people we've
reached out to you through every proper
channel i've tweeted a couple times
i'll give you about a two-week window
here to respond to us before i think
that this thing's just like some sort of
pr stunt like i'll give you a fair
interview and i hope
we can do it and by the way as it stands
right now
i support you caitlyn jenner because a
anyone's better than gavin newsom but
you've said some things
that make some sense so if you want to
have an honest conversation completely
unedited i won't bring any notes i'm not
trying to get you
just want to hear what you think please
do respond
to our people because we've reached out
through all the proper channels
so we're gonna talk about caitlyn jenner
who had some interesting things to say
about
girl girls in transport
trans girls in boys sports blah blah
blah it's all
backwards anyway uh and then finally ron
desantis is here to save america
and he's making it very clear that he's
the last guy and he's holding the line
and it's pretty spectacular so we're
gonna do all three of those
but before we get to it i want to talk
to you guys about hartford gold you know
i spend a lot of time
talking about cancel culture i think you
do that and how the left tries to
silence people
on issues that they don't want to hear
about well here's something
that we cannot cancel no matter how hard
we close our eyes or plug our ears
the biden administration is spending
excessively while killing energy jobs
and dragging out lockdowns and at the
truth
this can be catastrophic for the
american dollar which is why it's smart
to invest in things that are real with
intrinsic value which is why i'm
encouraging you to invest in gold
i recommend you speak to my friends at
american hartford gold they sell
physical gold and silver delivered right
to your door
or inside your ira plus they make it
easy and with an
a plus rating from the better business
bureau and thousands of satisfied
clients i know you will come to trust
them
too when you call today they'll give you
up to
1 500 worth of free silver with your
first order so now's a great time to
check them out
call 866 219 9311 that's 866 219-9311 or
text
reuben to 65532
don't wait secure your financial future
with gold and now back to me okay so i
want to do this story on jimmy kimmel
because it happened a couple days ago
after
tim scott's rebuttal to the joe biden
speech and it shows you a real
issue here that we're not able to
discuss in a mainstream sense now
i get it we're not able to discuss a lot
of things in a mainstream sense with
getting a wide swath
of people understanding but if you want
to see what sort of what i would say is
the
liberal elite modern woke
progressive racist view of the world
well here's jimmy kimmel after the
speech
an amazing thing happened after the
speech every black republican senator
got together to let the american people
know
the republican party isn't racist by
doubling down on the divisions
we've worked so hard to heal you know
this stuff is wrong
hear me clearly america
is not a racist country and then tim
promptly returned to the sensory
deprivation egg he calls home
senator scott accused democrats in his
rebuttal of using race as a weapon when
the truth is we're more concerned about
people using weapons as a weapon
race would be a terrible weapon what
would you do melon in a person to death
i didn't laugh there once did you was
there anything funny there the guy's got
like 20 writers makes probably 20
million bucks a year
before i comment specifically on what
was wrong with everything jimmy kimmel
said right there let's look at a picture
of jimmy kimmel in blackface
yeah there he is that's jimmy kimmel
making fun of carl malone
and in the video the original video of
that one of the things he does is
carmelo
used to talk about himself in the third
person all the time so carmelo played
really good defense tonight carmelo did
this that the other thing so he's making
fun of carmelo and the way he speaks
and he's obviously in blackface and that
by the way is one of the reasons
that jimmy kimmel has to constantly bow
to wokeness because all of these people
sasha baron cohen who's made fun of
you know gay people with bruno and all
of these people or
you know hank azarian the simpsons who's
done gay characters in bird cage
all of these people who feel bad about
what they've done
not what you've done they then bowed
awokeness because they think it gets
them
the get out of jail free card but jimmy
kimmel is a racist he is a modern racist
you know
racism has changed in a certain degree
we don't as i said before have people
that want separate water fountains
there's just
there's just it just doesn't exist and
he says the whole republican party is
racist what policy
is the republican party pushing that's
racist what par what policy
is the republican party pushing that
says oh because you're this skull skin
color
you should have access to this and
because you're this in color you
shouldn't or we're going to punish you
based on your race now the democrats are
we talked about it last week the
democrats every single democrat in the
senate
signed a bill that allows for
discrimination against asian people so
the democrats if we're if we're playing
this game
the democrats are systemically racist
the republicans are not
by the way he says the one black
republican in the senate
you know how many there are uh democrats
you know how many black democratic
senators there are
two two so there's two so there's one
more now you could say we should have
more
we can have a full healthy debate i
frankly don't care what the
racial makeup of the senate is i care if
these people want to stay the hell out
of my life that would be good for me
i would much rather have a white guy
that wants to stay out of my life than a
black guy who wants to tell me how to
live or some version of all of that like
these
this obsession with race and then the
way he says
you know he should go back to his
sensory deprivation chamber
the implication that he doesn't know
what's going on you know he doesn't know
but jimmy kimmel good jimmy kimmel knows
now
just to be very very clear when i say
jimmy kimmel is a racist i'm not being
hyperbolic
or over the top jimmy kimmel is a modern
racist
what he believes is that black people
who don't
think the way he thinks or at least the
way he wants them to think
that they are somehow less than or their
sellouts or their uncle tom's
or a whole bunch of stuff that i won't
say you get that
what he is saying is you better think
like me black guy and what i mean by
that is
you better believe in the democratic
party you better be a good
woke progressive democrat and live on
your knees forever
that makes you a good black man and the
thing is guys
when i say all this i don't care if
democrats are black or white
or republicans are green or asian or
blue
i judge people on their ideas but what
he's saying is you
tim scott don't get it because you don't
think what i want you to think
he is this is the modern pernicious
racism of the left and by the way this
is what's being imported
into schools and into our institutions
and everything else you i'm sure some of
you saw my interview last week with paul
rossi
from grace church school in new york
city they are
actually teaching this stuff in schools
this is not made up by the way i said
that jimmy kimmel probably makes 20
million
a year he only makes a cool 15 million
dollars a year so that means that abc
right a giant corporate company pays
that
racist man to peddle his divisive drivel
15 million dollars a year that's more
than i make it's more than you guys make
it's more than these guys make so it's
it's a lot of dough okay america is
divided right now we get it we all
understand it
and the division is being driven by
these people
but don't take my word for it because
here's a fascinating tweet that i saw
over the weekend from abc and if you
want to see how it all fits into sort of
fake news and confusion and why we can't
agree on anything listen to how this
tweet
is worded and then we'll dive into the
actual article itself this is from abc
23 of americans think the country has
become
more united under president since
president biden took office according to
a new
abc news poll among this group
an overwhelming 87 percent give biden
credit so if you
look at that just sort of on face value
it kind of sounds good oh
23 think that the countries become more
united that's pretty solid and then of
course the 87
within that well that's just irrelevant
but it kind of sounds good but if you
think about it well
23 percent i think america's got
america's got more united well then
what about the other 77 can we look into
that so actually
we dove into the article because that's
what we do around here and here's a
quote from the article on abc
only about a quarter of americans 23
percent think the country has become
more united since biden took office
six in ten here's the key part people
six in ten
think biden is more responsible for the
divisions
compared to 34 percent who say
both biden and republicans are culpable
for sowing division
only 6 percent faulted republicans
so only six percent of the people that
were polled
said that this is the republicans fault
six in ten
sixty percent i'm not a mathemagician
but i can do that much
six and ten are saying that it's biden's
fault but if you look at the tweet
you'd go oh 23 percent you know think by
you know helping out here and making us
less racist and
more together in that whole thing anyway
i thought it was worth mentioning
because this is the we constantly see
this with the media
anything that they can spin they take
numbers
that are obviously not good for biden
and they tweet it out and
frame it in such a way that it makes it
seem like it's something positive
and then for the few people that
actually click into the article because
we know people don't
it's only there if you'd put the whole
thing together that you'd go oh actually
60 percent of people think it's
the reverse of what the headline kind of
reads right there so
anyway jimmy kimmel you're a racist uh
let's talk about uh gabby insurance you
know when it comes to car and home
insurance
don't we deserve better i know i do i
put my policy to test and turn to gabby
they literally stand for get
a better insurance getting better
insurance with gabby means a better
price for the same insurance
coverage who knew something like this
existed they are the one
true comparison platform with real rates
they give you an apples-to-apples
comparison of your current coverage with
40 of the top insurance providers
like progressive nationwide and
travelers and all in one place
use your con your current insurance
information to get started and in just
minutes you'll be able to see quotes for
the exact same coverage you currently
have and it's free to use
it's fast and easy and gabby can show
you if you've been overpaying when i did
it i discovered great insurance quotes
and was quickly able to compare the top
five rates by seeing them listed in
order
which made navigating through the plans
super easy they have great customer
service and support as well
gabby customers save 961 dollars per
year on average
and they'll never sell your info so no
annoying spam or robo calls
put your policy to the test like i did
get a better insurance with gabby it's
totally free to check
and there's no obligation go to
gabby.com reuben that's g-a-b-i
dot com slash reuben g-a-b-i dot com
slash reuben and now back to me
all right caitlyn jenner who just about
a week ago announced that
she is running for governor of
california
because gavin newsom the evil cartoon
character known as gavin newsom
uh the evil psychopath known as gavin
newsom the man who i hope ends up in
jail
because he's destroyed so many people's
lives gavin newsom he is being recalled
whether he likes it or not and even in
our deeply deeply
corrupt one-party state here in
california they couldn't invalidate
enough votes they needed 1.5 million
basically
they got over 2 million they invalidated
something like 400
000 of them but even with all of the
machinery that they have to just
destroy every sense of democracy uh
they couldn't do it and the recall is
happening so at the moment
a couple people have jumped in to say
that they are going to run against gavin
newsom because again
the recall does not mean that gavin
newsom is gone it means that he
has he now has to run again so there's
just a new election being called
caitlyn jenner is one of the people and
by the way for i don't
ever see comments like this but if just
to make it very clear
i have no problem personally calling
caitlyn jenner a she
she has decided to transition right
bruce jenner who was born biologically a
male and still biologically is a male
everyone under everyone's sensible
understands that i can't say everyone
understands that
but he has chosen to live life as a
trans woman
and as long as he as long as she say it
happens every now and again but as long
as she was to treat me with respect
and and be a you know functional decent
member of society then i would certainly
treat them with respect
so that is how i have no problem using
gender pronouns in that way i know some
people struggle with that that's my
personal take on it like i have no
problem
personally calling caitlyn a she that's
very different than wanting
young biological girls that are six
years old to suddenly have all of these
crazy surgeries and everything else that
i'm completely not for and i'm certainly
not for it when it's mandated and pushed
by the state
for more on that you should check my uh
interview with abigail schreier from a
couple months ago and we'll get to more
on her in just a second but in any event
caitlyn jenner
went out this weekend she was just
getting coffee with her dog
and tmz got up in her face
hi caitlin so there's legislation in
various states to ban biological boys
who are trans from playing girl sports
in school what's your opinion on that
inbox
this is a question of fairness
that's why i oppose biological boys who
are trans
competing in girl sports in school it
just
isn't fair and we have to protect
girl sports but it just
isn't fair and we have to protect girls
sports in our schools everything that
caitlyn jenner
said right there is truthful now you can
have whatever feelings you have about
caitlyn jenner
about trans people about celebrities in
politics all of those things
all legit you can you can have whatever
personal beliefs you want to have on all
of those things
we live in such a wacked out state that
maybe we can only get celebrities and
maybe we can only get bizarre reality
stars and former athletes and
people who've transitioned like maybe
all of these things is the best
california can choke out but i promise
you
that right there caitlyn is better
than gavin newsom everything she said
there was true she's protecting girls no
one's against
trans people you know they've really
what they've done here is so perverse
because they're trying every time this
is framed in the mainstream media
they're trying to make it seem
that any state that passes a law on this
is somehow against
trans girls all they're saying is
they're not banning
trans girls from sports they're saying
you have to
compete in the category
of the same biological sex that you are
that's all and if you want there to be a
trans category i actually don't think
anyone have a problem with that
so there's such a bizarre thing here and
again we know there's biological
differences and that's why
the best wnba player whoever that might
be i have no freaking clue
is could never play in the in the nba
the best wnba player
would be worse than the worst nba player
this is just a fact
this is just fact that's why we have an
nba and a wnba
that's not a judgment on women or
women's biology or women playing
basketball or anything else i mentioned
to you guys
a couple times over the years i went to
the same high school as sue bird she's
thought of as the best wnba player i'm
not even sure
i think she's still playing sue bird can
we confirm that but she's older now so
uh but in any event she won a wnba
mvp many times i'm a little older than
her but i used to play with her every
now and again
at the community park and this girl
could break ankles and do all sorts of
awesome crossovers and she had a great
shot and she was quick and all of those
things
but sue bird the wnba player would not
get a minute in the nba that's different
so it's perfectly fine that men and
women
have different leagues that's perfectly
fine and if you're born with a certain
set of characteristics physical
attributes then you should play in that
league so it's very odd i mean this is
this is the odd thing that a whole bunch
of us
have uh have warned about for a long
time
is that in the name of doing something
that was good which is which is that we
want respect
for trans people and we want people to
be able to live a fully
self-actualized life and all those
things we've now we
it's really they the the feminists let's
say and the workstars and the
progressives they've all come out to be
the most
anti-woman movement possible absolutely
anti-woman movement i actually saw
another video that was
pretty disturbing this morning some
woman tweeted out her
her tick tock video talking to her
daughter
who was a bit of a tomboy probably like
three or four years old he was a
she was a tomboy like that's it that's
fine some girls like sports some boys
like barbie
who cares maybe maybe the girl would
turn out to be a lesbian maybe a boy
that plays with barbies would turn out
to be gay
that's who nobody cares about any of
this stuff but the mother is basically
encouraging her
to be a girl and this is the very
twisted thing that we've done
uh by the way just to uh confirm sue
bird is the longest
tenured player in the wnba but the point
is at her peak
so let's say sue bird at 28 years old at
her absolute physical peak
could have never played in the nba and
that's why we have separate leagues and
that's just fine
i mentioned abigail schreier before who
of course wrote a wonderful book
about the the sort of collective
madness around young girls specifically
transitioning
to be boys and abigail i just want to
say is an absolutely fantastic person
we just had dinner with her husband
they're great people the idea that these
people are bigots in any way
or have any sort of other agenda than
just
letting people live as who they are but
not letting the state mandate
who can you know change their body as a
child and all of these things it's just
nuts but she had an interesting tweet on
this she said here are a few
important things i know about caitlyn
jenner she
won led america to olympic gold two
is devoted to her family three stands up
to the woke
four defends women's sports five isn't
gavin newsom
so far she has my vote there you go
i i stand with abigail on that i stand
with caitlyn on that
now the question is for california
moving off the trans topic for just a
sec
is like should we have more people
involved that's not a shot at caitlyn
and again i really would like to
interview caitlyn let's see how real
this thing is and is she really ready to
fight
and is this not just for a reality show
or something else but like
we all know so much is wrong with this
state and there's all sorts of numbers
now on on the amount of people fleeing
the state and moving
to austin so they're going to ruin
austin texas sorry austin
um and of course a lot of them are going
to florida and
i would recommend florida as i tweeted
out this morning build a wall and start
training an army
um nobody's moving here but it's like we
all know that california
is in a crisis it's like can we get some
other candidates like let's
get some other candidates and for those
of you that are going dave why don't you
run
you know the phone call the 3am hello
governor rubin there's been an
earthquake in santa barbara it's like
what do you want me to do what can you
call me back like i just can't deal with
that i got my own problems you know what
i'm saying
and that's the part of the problem with
politics by the way they're all good
decent
sort of functioning people who who are
producing things in life
why would you want anything to do with
politics instead in politics you get a
whole bunch of people
who just want to control you and tell
you how to live this is a major
schism in the in the mind of humans that
we have to negotiate with it's like
that that actually is the best argument
for why these people should have no
power over us because the only people
who would want to get in
generally speaking want power over us
but that's a perfect transition to a guy
who doesn't seem to want to have a ton
of power over
the people that voted him in and of
course i'm talking about florida
governor ron desantis who i have no
problem saying is absolutely
the best governor in the country right
now and
i would vote for him for president in a
second
and he's doing all of the right things
like if you just check off what are the
right things
a man is just doing it doing it doing it
so first off
he signed just in the last couple of
days a bill
banning social media d platforming
which is obviously something we've
talked quite a bit about this is from
the new york post
social media companies would be unable
to permanently kick people off their
platforms
under a tough new florida law the bill
passed by the gop dominated state
legislature thursday
and awaiting governor ron desantis's
signature would make it a crime to
remove
state political candidates from twitter
and facebook and would met out penalties
of 250 grand a day
for any statewide candidate who is
de-platformed
the bill also requires tech companies to
give users seven days notice that they
are at risk of being banned and offer
them the opportunity to correct the
issue
suspensions of up to 14 days would still
be allowed so this is super interesting
now now specifically what the bill is
going for there in case you missed it in
the weeds
is that candidates who were bd platform
that would affect candidates not
necessarily private citizens
i suspect there'll be some debate about
that the other question is how much
power
does a state government have over these
tech companies and you know if they have
offices in in florida if not like
what are the actual levers that can get
these uh states to do anything
and this is one of the interesting ones
because i know obviously we have a lot
of libertarian-minded people watching
this show and of course i consider
myself in that bucket
it's like one of those ones where it's
like you don't really want the
government to come in and tell these
companies what to do or how
they have what process they have to have
for suspending people
or all of those things but this is where
to me to me
and i discussed this a couple weeks ago
with nick gillespie and i'm happy to
discuss it with
with anyone else actually on either side
of the issue i really am
at some point the libertarian stuff hits
the real world right you get the rubber
meets the road moment and if
you in some cases i would say
uncomfortably have to use the levers of
government and that's why i would say
i'm i'm not an
anarchist in a traditional sense sort of
like michael malus who i'm going to have
on again in a couple weeks who i
absolutely
love talking to and it's a fun
conversation everything else but here
is the government doing a little
something this is not the government
taking over the tech companies
it's not the government really
regulating them in any sort of concrete
sense
it's saying hey can you have some basic
minimum stuff here which is you're not
going to kick political candidates off
and you know if you're going to have a
problem with someone you're going to
have
some sort of you know window a 14-day
window
for them to correct the issue etcetera
etcetera it seems to me like the bare
minimum that a government
could do so desantis is trying whether
again he has the full
apparatus because he's just a governor
to do
all of this stuff will will be seen but
like he's trying he's absolutely trying
and speaking of trying just this morning
this video went up just about an hour
ago
governor ron desantis has announced that
he's going to suspend all
local covet 19 emergency orders in
florida let's take a look
now today i'm going to let the
legislatures come up but what i'm going
to do i'm going to sign the bill
it's effective july 1st i'll also sign
an executive order pursuant to that bill
invalidating all remaining
local emergency covet orders effective
on july 1st
but then to bridge the gap between then
and now i'm going to suspend
under my executive power the local
emergency orders as it relates to covid
i think that's the evidence-based thing
to do
i think the fact
i think i think folks that are saying
that they need to be policing people at
this point
if you're saying that you really are
saying you don't believe in the vaccines
you don't believe in the data you don't
believe in the science uh
we've embraced the vaccines we've
embraced the science on it
the data i've said has been good from
the beginning in terms of clinical
trials
it's even better in real life and so
it's available we want everyone to get
it and if you get it just know
that the reason you get it is because we
want to be able to have people
enjoy themselves and live live freely in
the state of florida
we want to have people live freely
and enjoy themselves in the state of
florida you get it that's not a guy
who became the chief executive of a
state to run
everyone's life that's a guy who's doing
the right
blend of science and social policy
and liberty and saying hey we're going
to trust the science where we can trust
it
but we're also not going to destroy
everyone's lives and we're going to let
you make some decisions and that is in
such
deeply stark contrast with clowns like
gavin newsom
who still has california under lockdown
until june 15th which is a completely
arbitrary date
except that it's a little bit closer to
the recall and he might need a little
good news when the recall starts really
percolating so oh and now we'll let you
be free
now by the way everyone's ignoring it
there's traffic again
out in california finally over the last
couple days
outdoors you're seeing people uh you
know take off their masks i haven't been
wearing a mask outdoors in forever
but you're seeing life just move and you
know there's something interesting
there's two interesting things happening
here one
directly related to federalism which you
guys know i talk about this all the time
that
in many ways what's happening to the
united states is exactly what the
founders intended which is that
states will live very differently you
will have different laws in different
states and you will have the foot vote
your ability to live
where you want now i know that i get it
i get it with the irony thing dave you
live in california
i'm fighting to get rid of this governor
and then we'll we'll go from there right
and i don't want to live in a country
really where it's like certain people
just
can't live in certain states like if
someone like me really
truly cannot live in california then
what does that really say
about the union like it kind of says
that it's over like are we ending up in
another
civil war type situation or just some
mass separation or
something like that so you know the idea
though that florida's doing it their way
and they're seeing
the good results and texas is doing it
their way and they're seeing the good
results and california's doing what
they're doing and new york's doing
what they're doing it's like that
actually is
good so i'm happy to see that
and then at the same time it's like well
you know if we're gonna end up
in this new york is this way california
is this way you know florida texas or
that way
but what do we do what do we do you know
i don't know what the answer to that is
i don't even really like talking about
it actually
because it sort of feeds the idea that
we're in some really intractable
broken situation here and maybe we are
and maybe that's exactly why the
founders laid it out the way that they
did
so maybe that is sort of the silver
lining to all of this
um anyway you know i woke up this
morning and i just had a pretty good
feeling about the week
there's been a couple other stories
where in different states
going through state legislatures right
now they're fighting back against
critical race theory getting it out of
the curriculum and by the way that's not
a free speech issue i see a lot of
people saying oh you see now the
conservatives are coming for free speech
no no one's saying you can't have your
ridiculous ideas and you can't say them
but we should not be teaching your
horrific racist
ideas in in state schools and maybe we
shouldn't have state schools
either that would be a little bit of
that uh anarcho-capitalist stuff that
michael malus
and i will talk about in a couple weeks
uh for more guys part
two of my interview with former south
carolina
governor and former u.s ambassador to
the u.n nikki haley
is up part one dropped last week we
actually did it live in studio right
here and we are gonna
be sort of smattering in a few more live
in person things
uh as things have sort of shaken out and
i did kind of realize in the midst of it
that i really kind of missed seeing
people and not just talking to that
so part two is up on youtube right now
part one of course is up at
reubenreport.locals.com and today is
meme monday over there so we're sharing
some funny memes and
and i respond to people there also you
know i can't really respond to people on
twitter or youtube comments
or anywhere else it's just too much time
and too many crazy people and bots and
russian trolls and ukrainian agents and
god knows what else
but if you want to talk to me directly
you can at rubinreport.locals.com
all right that's monday for you have a
great week everybody and we'll be back
tomorrow